Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we will host a FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us for a brand new week!
And here today for our 144th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO-chan, you're feeling much better now, right?
I feel better.
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you!
But it's a new week!
So we're ready.
Maybe, maybe there's some Ruffians out.
This is your first time today.
If I ask, Ruffians is gonna be, yeah, all gonna be saying, yeah, my first time.
I feel like there's some Ruffians out.
Maybe there's a first time?
Yeah.
I'm feeling buff.
What?
I'm feeling buff, Moco-chan.
My head was feeling buff.
In a bad way, right?
You new here?
I don't think you new here.
Those that are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday and Monday.
Taken in FUWAMOCO and is hosted by us,
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet it onto the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO morning!
BAU BAU!
Hashtag hashtag.
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
First time you watch FUWAMOCO Morning this week?
Wow!
It's a new week?
I wouldn't expect that.
BAU BAU!
Let's start it off on the right paw.
Right, Moco-chan?
You know, I think the Ruffians noticed something's a little bit different today about FUWAMOCO Morning.
Some things don't really change that much.
Huh?
Ruffians.
It's been another Pero sighting!
BAU BAU!
I do appreciate the Pero Sightings, Ruffians, but you know what?
Making sure that all the Ruffians don't have to deal with the nastiness, but I'm just sad about that.
Why does it have to be the beginning every time, FUWAMOCO-chan?
Why is this important?
Well, let's see where Pero will spoil the day.
Okay.
Let's check it out.
De-den!
Huh?
Someone very nasty decided to sneak into your bed.
He's not going back to bed, is he?
Huh?
Don't try to make the Ruffians sleepy again, Pero, okay?
Cute?
Not cute!
No!
Ugly!
It does look comfy there with us on either side, but... You know, Ruffians, the new week is just starting!
You know you can't go back to bed!
You know, it might still be cold outside, but once you get warning in a- warning?
Once you get a warning, you'll be warm.
Very ominous!
Five more minutes?
No!
No, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning is now!
It started four minutes ago!
Yeah, so... No more five more minutes!
A day has started!
It's gonna start on the right paw!
Don't let Pero entice you back into battle, kay?
Does he fit well underneath your arm?
Does he?
Tempting.
Gotta watch out, cute Ruffians, before you know it, there'll be a tongue there.
Why?
In your armpit!
Yeah.
Gotta be careful.
Try your own caution.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You might have heard all of a sudden there was a question question question mark on our schedule before last week.
But the other day we actually had a collab with Subaru-senpai over on her channel!
BAU BAU!
Now we went to Subaru no Koya!
Ojamashimashita!
Subaru's sack?
Shack sack?
Cabin.
Cabin?
I think some Ruffians got confused and thought we went to Subaru-senpai's cabin by the lake.
No.
Subaru's place.
Yes.
But...
Ojamashimashita yo!
We are in the facility together with Subaru-senpai and she asked us a bunch of different questions.
Also by you Ruffians and Subaru-tomo!
Thank you Ruffians for so many great questions!
I know we chatted a bunch.
Omoshirokatta!
Yokatta!
A bunch of different things we talked about you know.
Somehow we ended up talking about a lot of different very
Otaku-like topics.
There was a mention of a new holo somewhere called Holosukumisu.
I don't know, that was just maybe something Subaru-senpai was secretly thinking about.
Oh, it was Subaru-senpai that brought it up, right?
Yes!
Yeah.
Or maybe it's in Subatomo!
Yes, blame the Subatomo, yes.
Don't blame her!
Okay, but blame the Subatomo.
But there was some very heated discussion too about glasses and socks.
Subaru-senpai never told us what kind of glasses are her favorite.
I wanna hear more about what Subaru-senpai likes for glasses.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
That's the last question, you know.
But you know, after week 2 we got to chat a bunch with Subaru-senpai.
So we're really really happy.
We got a bunch of helpful advice and tips.
You know Subaru-senpai was so kind and welcoming.
We also got sent on a little journey too!
We did!
Otsukai!
To get some lettuce and buns.
And some coffee mugs.
It was fun.
If you want this brand or this brand or this one or the big one or the small one.
We are really really happy to be able to help you.
We hope that you go check it out.
It's on Subaru-senpai's channel.
But hopefully we can go out together with Subaru-senpai soon again.
Thank you for having us over Subaru-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
If you were listening too, maybe you heard.
But while doing a collab with Subaru-senpai, there was a little corner.
Yeah, a wheel.
Yeah, we spawned a special wheel.
And, FUWAMOCO, we happened to land on the shared secret that you haven't shared.
Square.
Pizza.
Slice.
It wasn't really a square.
Slice, yeah.
But, well...
Thought and thought and thought and then realized!
A new arrival!
To the doghouse!
FUWAMOCO!
We got our paws on an ASMR mode!
It's happening!
How beautiful!
Excited?
We still don't have it set up.
No, not at all.
We are unpacked.
Good job, FUWAMOCO.
Good job, F
I know we're going to start learning with the Doggy Pack membership.
Maybe first after doing some training here and there.
So we hope that you'll listen with kind ears there.
I could've definitely stumbled.
My ears are saying that they can't wait.
We'll learn together, okay?
Yeah, Chou-senpai would love to give us ASMR lessons.
We like that too, but... Yeah... But we still just, you know, in for more... Puppies?
Babies?
We're still at the starting line.
We'll definitely stumble lots, but... Yeah, but we're still nervous.
We don't really know that much, you know.
But that is true, you know.
We do have a little bit of experience because, well, we released earlier last year.
Hey, voice FUWAMOCO is a live voice produced by Patra Onee-san!
And you can get it like now the hololive official shop too, but, you know, now with this don't mean we can do some streams.
But, there's definitely a lot of learning still needed.
Definitely accidents that will happen.
Especially Moco-chan.
Look forward to it!
BAU BAU!
But speaking of the voice... Ruffians!
I don't know.
Somehow, it keeps on happening.
This is my new voice pack!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at which one it is this time.
We have...
Partner voice pack.
What is this?
It's different from the detective voice pack.
Right.
Detectives have a partner, but this is a partner voice pack.
Are you keeping up with them, Mofi?
Every month you already got them?
I don't know if it's every month.
I feel like it's almost every week now.
Right.
But this time, you know, I think most recently there was the Noises voice pack.
And the Enrico voice pack.
And the Spring Revelry voice pack.
Partner voice pack.
Detective voice pack.
No!
The partner voice pack!
What?
What's the partner voice pack, Moco-chan?
What part is?
I'm searching for something.
We're searching.
We're fireflies together!
Moco-chan.
Partners in crime?
Kind of like that without the, you know... Without the crime, just fireflies.
At this time, Ruffians!
For the first time, we get to do yoga together!
I'm gonna teach you.
Although I don't really know that much, so...
Oh my goodness, you are about to get a nice stretch.
A stretch?
Not stress.
Stretch together, so... Hopefully we don't become soggy doggies or anything, but... I see a lot more yoga, yoga, yoga, no... Fireflies!
I don't know, Moco-chan.
Maybe the Ruffians just feel a little like... A little tight, you know, and you get a bit stressed.
You're not one of me, my partner!
I don't know if fireflies are downward dogs or not.
Hi!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, either way to go, you can go and take a listen to the sample on the hololive official song.
And if you want to be partners in crime, maybe the detective voice pack is good for you too.
It's still available, so please check it out!
BAU BAU!
We'll continue to do our best at the voice packs, but Ruffians,
There's a lot of them.
So we hope that you have a lot of fun and maybe you find which one is, you know, this is definitely my kind of thing.
The voice pack for me.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's mine!
No, it's FUWAMOCO morning.
It's morning.
Yeah.
It's fun.
It's really lovely here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, Ruffians, we also have some news, you know.
Maybe for some busy Ruffians, you're kind of like, huh?
Wait, what's going on?
Maybe you didn't even notice.
But...
FUWAMOCO!
Good news!
We beat Little Witch Nobita!
BAU BAU!
Maybe like, huh?
This isn't a new game.
I haven't heard of this game.
You've been playing a game like this?
Yes, we have.
We have been.
Last time we played it was on September 2023.
Yeah.
Yeah!
We did it!
We finally did it!
It was a hard game, right Moco-chan?
Yes.
It was originally.
Yeah.
On controller it was hard.
On keyboard it was not.
Yeah!
That long in between, huh?
You know there's a lot of fun things.
I was good, right?
Yeah.
Only dodging.
You know when you have a lot of fun things going on, sometimes other fun things happen in between.
And then before you know, some months go by.
And then before you know, six months go by.
Yeah.
But we did it!
And there's been a lot of improvement.
So much improvement that our save data disappeared.
But that's okay because Moco-chan is a pro and no bosses stopped you.
I got the save data more or less back before.
Yeah, and we got lots of costumes.
Please play more Soul Link.
Soul Link?
Like what one?
Is there more with cute girls?
Those legs are cute girls.
Maybe one with dark souls.
I have a feeling it doesn't help.
A cute dragon princess?
A cute crab?
Crabs are cute, but a cute crab is different from a cute girl.
Dragon princess?
Crab princess?
Sure.
I'll go for that.
Huh?
I see a lot of different games.
I've never heard of these ones so I'll have to search them up.
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Hi.
Maybe some could suggest these cute turtles.
Is that the title of the game?
Hi.
Now I'm picturing what like a soulslug would look like with a turtle.
I don't think it'd be very fast.
It could just... Oh, true.
I was picturing a fast turtle, you know, that could run really well because the shell is hard.
No.
It would be a long game.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for waiting so long to see Nobeta's conclusion!
If you haven't seen Nobeta before, please check it out as well, even though it's more or less from the start.
Don't worry!
BAU BAU!
We're happy to be able to complete it!
Moco-chan, you were very confident about it.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You might have kind of heard but right now currently we have a very special collaboration going on with an apparel brand called Anime Gear Girls!
BAU BAU!
Anime gear gonna make special anime-inspired apparel.
And this time, you can get your paws on FUWAMOCO-themed jackets and more!
Have you seen it on Twitter?
Maybe!
So cool!
Is that a onesie?
It is not a onesie!
It's even better than that!
But finally, Ruffians!
The time has come!
You can have matching jackets together!
Hey guys!
As you can see, we have Fuwawa fans!
Look at my jacket.
It's very faithfully replicated, but you know, a little bit more functional maybe for you Ruffians.
You know, it's just as long as my jacket.
It has a little, you know, a little cutout there for my tail.
Maybe not as convenient for you, but I'll explain.
But it's a long denim jacket.
It's very, very, very, very close.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Next we have my jacket!
It's also detachable, but this time it goes into a short crop Mococo-style denim jacket!
It can be a bit hard to imagine, but we'll still put photos here, okay?
Let's take a look maybe.
You know, both jackets have very high quality embroidery and it's also a very heavy fabric.
It's a heavy weighted denim.
Yeah, you know, you might think, is the jacket fuzzy?
No, it's not fuzzy.
It's anime inspired, right?
So you know, like, the design you think would be most important.
But, obviously the design is very important.
But the materials, like, this is a very, very... We were very surprised that it's very, very durable, heavy material.
It's going to keep you warm.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Special hats!
Yes!
Not just jackets!
There's two different hats.
Both a dad hat and a bucket hat.
This is a bucket hat.
This is a dad hat.
I think.
No.
A hat.
This is a dad hat!
Not just a bucket hat.
This is a dad hat.
This is the one that has the front.
The one that looks like a duck.
But it's a dad hat.
Yeah.
Yes!
But they also have very nice embroidery on them as well!
Right!
Yeah, mom's wearing it.
Yes.
If you maybe take a closer look once you get your paws on it, you'll be really surprised.
There's some secrets too.
But!
Why don't you take a look at some of the photos?
Okay, so the jacket is very heavy in denim and it's gonna keep you warm.
But the lining is so cute and it's really plushy and warm and soft.
And it has a kind of like, a bit of a shiny, like a shininess to it.
It's a very nice liner.
Very nice.
It's kind of like, you know, almost like a blanket kind of.
Very ruffy.
I don't want to tell.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Pretty big zipper, so you know you're not gonna have to worry about... Actually, I can't get it off or I can't get it back on!
We were checking out the sample and one thing we sort of discovered is that, you know, if you have a friend that maybe forgot their jacket and they're home...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
That's what I was doing, I was using it as a shawl.
And there's so many pockets too, Ruffians!
If you like pockets, there's pockets!
And for Mococo, you can also see it has the detachable part.
It's literally a regular jacket, but an amulet.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I don't want my arm in the frame.
But you want to be cool.
Like an anime character and put it on your shoulder.
Yeah.
You're going to maybe walk through like a big gust of wind.
But you don't really... You want to have your arms free.
Yeah.
That's exactly what you could do, you know.
Like a cape.
Yes, exactly!
But cooler than a cape.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
That was the secret all along, and now you can be the hero!
You can be Moco-chan, you can be Fuwawa, it's all up to you!
Yeah, and then we have a close-up on the hat too!
There's lots of embroidery, so it's very very nice.
You know, both Fuwawa and Moco-chan, so you know you're like, I don't know, I don't know which jacket I like, I like both jackets!
You know?
Well, we actually have some extra details here!
Due to high demand, the pre-order period has actually been extended until April 30th, 2025.
So make sure you get your pre-order in before then!
You still have time, Ruffians, but don't forget why!
There's also a special limited offer where if you're indecisive or you're like, you know, I love jackets, I want to be warm.
If you get both jackets, you'll also receive both hats for free!
BAU BAU!
And there's also free shipping to the US for orders of over $150 or more!
But because of the updated pre-order period, the shipping time is estimated now to be late July to early August 2025.
So you know maybe it'll arrive just in back when it's starting to get
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Free shipping!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Let's take a look, you know we looked at some doggies.
Now let's take a look at who's the Doggie of the Day today.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... It's Zeus!
BAU BAU!
Hi!
Look at the sparkly round eyes!
I'm here, what are you doing?
But Zeus is in fact a chihuahua and a beagle mix.
No Fuwawa or demon dog here.
But he really loves to cuddle.
Look at the super cute and fashionable sweater.
I want a sweater like that.
Zeus also has a nice cute jacket, huh?
Right.
I wish he had one.
I don't know, if I had a sweater like that, it might not suit me as well as it suits Zeus.
We're not supposed to underestimate him because he looks cute, but... No!
He's cute!
Wow, Moco-chan, how does Zeus bow-bow?
Maybe like... Awai!
Awai!
Like that!
Zeus!
The Beagle Chihuahua Mix!
BAU BAU!
I'm cute!
Well, this is, yeah, a bagel-chihuahua mix.
But, I feel like you know more than the chihuahua part.
I see the bagel, maybe the bagel, the gourmet bagel part coming up.
Bagel bread!
Baked toasted!
Gourmet bagel!
Yeah, and a bouncy cafe, you know!
Can be like, oh, what do you like on your cafe?
FUWAMOCO
But Zeus is very cute.
Looks like a very sweet doggy.
But you know, Zeus is Zeus.
Maybe not so powerful like the god in the sky yet.
No, it's just a gourmet bagel.
But you know, I'm sure that he'll become a great guard dog soon.
BAU BAU!
Bagel for now.
And for today, I wanna walk!
Ruffians!
Let's go on a walk, huh?
Let's check it out!
De-den!
Let's walk around Shinjuku on the way!
And you know, it's a very necessary stop at Mise-d'oeuvre!
Ruffians!
Why?
Why would you eat a pon-de-ring like this?
You know, well, you can eat it however you feel is most delicious to you, right?
That's okay.
But, uh, this is a first!
I don't know.
I feel like it's almost hard to look at, right?
Right.
I don't want to look at it.
Yeah, if you look really hard at it, it kind of looks like, you know, a pon-de-ring has been turned inside out.
I know.
Yeah, how do you even eat it like that?
Right, right.
It looks cool.
I think that's wrong.
Godzilla did it, I don't know about that.
We're gonna blame it on Godzilla.
No, I don't think that's fair.
I don't think Yofi-senpai would be okay with that.
We have to think of Yofi-senpai right now.
We're being considerate.
We hope you enjoyed it even though you ate it interestingly in an inside out way.
But hopefully Godzilla didn't surprise you too much either.
BAU BAU!
And for the Question of the Day!
What question did we receive from the Ruffians?
De-den!
Oh, I'm curious!
You both went back for a bit to the northwest passage, right?
How are the plants you have back there doing?
Did they have enough water?
It's been at the back of my mind for a while now.
FUWAMO- FUWAMO!
Me and some Ruffians have forgot FUWAMOCO-chan, you have some so cute plants!
I have some plants.
They're kind of like a cactus.
I almost said cat boy.
No.
I'm a puppy.
She's busy.
No, she forgot.
What do you think happened, Ruffians?
Any ideas?
Hi.
Well, uh... Actually, they didn't get any bigger.
Yeah.
Uh, no growing.
No growing.
But they didn't get crispy and dry either.
Yeah.
It's just like time stopped for them.
Yeah, time just stopped.
They're the exact same.
They look exactly the same.
Yeah.
Not any bigger, not any smaller, not any crispier.
Maybe a little bit.
A bit more dry.
Not very plump.
Yeah.
Ain't that interesting?
Right.
Yeah, but hopefully, no, hopefully Mama Puppy will remember tomorrow.
A bit more.
Yeah.
This is like the SNES.
Maybe they're plastic?
No, they're not plastic.
I don't like plastic ones.
I like the SNES!
I like the SNES.
The SNES is stopped in time kind of, right?
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
The hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Send us your questions and Doggie of the Day.
Pero Sightings too.
Yeah, I guess.
And you know, your walks too.
It's getting so much the time.
You know.
Maybe the cherry blossoms.
Maybe they're blooming.
Maybe there's daffodils blooming.
Maybe something else is blooming.
Maybe there's just something interesting.
Maybe your heart is booming.
Please let us know with the hashtag.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
And for our next jam!
Our next jam!
FUWAMOCO Ruffians, this week is a busy week for us.
And there's a lot of things that are still up in the air right now.
So we don't have a schedule yet.
But we'll let you know as soon as we can about our plans.
And if we're not able to see you before then, we'll see you next during the very next FUWAMOCO Morning!
We were trying to put together a schedule but...
It just keeps on changing.
That's why we've kind of been a little bit quiet about the schedule, so... Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for understanding, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians joining us in the archive today!
Your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU for puppies!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Jackal!
BAU BAU!
Beanie!
Pikmin!
BAU BAU!
Devs!
Mork mork mork!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!